>> Oh my goodness, I always forget how to add things. New, oh yea,
new fields. Okay, so purchase source, that's
a pick list right? Pick list just like.
>> A little drop down list you can
click and choose one of the definied values.
>> Sweet.
Okay, so the places you could buy a ticket would be. At the box office.
>> Box office.
>> The official website.
>> Official website, yeah.
>> What else?
>> Maybe like third-party ticket vendor.
>> Okay. Anything else?
>> maybe Facebook?
>> Oh yeah, yeah. Okay, and description, I guess
this is where the customer or attendee bought the ticket.
>> Yeah, and if
we wanted to add more values to the pick
list later, we could just go back and add them.
>> Okay, cool, right. So, moving on, Next. Lots of Next.
>> Default visibility, yeah.
>> Okay, I do want to add it to the Layout. Right?
>> Yeah.
>> I guess I should Save anew because I'm going to add a bunch more fields?
>> Yeah. Let's add the next one.
>> Okay, cool. So I'll finish that and add a few more fields.
>> Sounds good.